oh I don't know that it can teach us all
that much i mean i thought it was
overblown as being implemented of race
relations or profiling or anything of
that sort i didn't read it as you know
insightful or really useful in that
regard though I do think how we reacted
to the incident you know what it became
drawing the president in and so someone
perhaps would tell us something about
and this was my argument in the piece
how we process racial issues how we talk
and don't talk about them maybe how we
are quick to repair to some conventional
and Pat storyline about them you know
the country had a problem has had a
problem is trying to overcome it some
people are slower at that than others
there's a racist behind every bush let's
not tolerate the races this kind of talk
and I just thought the gates incident
and again the president's handling of it
showed the thinness of that narrative
how that line was probably not any
longer if ever it was adequate to
capture the you know the reality of our
racial condition if you will
pretend to omniscience here but I'd say
I'd say they're there are some asked
several aspects of it that I would point
out one is the continuing fact of a
developmental lag or gap between the
african-american population taken as a
whole not of course including every
person on the one hand and the rest of
the much of the rest of the country on
the other blacks are not the only group
of people who manifest certain of the
kinds of problems that I would talk
about here and that are reflected in
policing in prisons problems of poor
education and intermittent employment
and you know limited full human
development problems of fragile and
fractured communities and families of
large numbers of under socialized and
underdeveloped young people who end up
getting into trouble of you know and I
could go on you see the the line that
this would draw it would say that the
african-american population taken as a
whole lags behind on the average along
many of these dimensions this is a
stubborn reality and it has consequences
and it can't be easily reconciled with a
pat account about racism and
discrimination that lets us sort of
relax into saying you know when we
finally get this right when we get rid
of racism when we reach the post-racial
Society everything's going to be okay
well no because along the way here as
we've not yet been in this racial
Nirvana facts on the ground have been
created blighted lives have played
themselves out and human difficulties
have developed and these are stark
they're staring us in the face they're
the subtext for a lot of our politics
there that they're the story behind the
story so when gates a Harvard professor
god bless him I certainly intend him no
ill will
but when he trots out this story about a
racist rogue police officer and when he
begins to embrace this rhetoric of
racial profiling frankly and when the
president buys into this and unlike but
the wisdom that he typically exhibits
President Obama in conducting public
affairs makes a huge mistake by buying
into this it is a distraction from the
real story the real story two and a
quarter million Americans half of whom
are black under lock and key on a given
day the real story stop-and-frisk as the
police technique de jour in City after
City around this country where the
rubber hits the road in terms of
profiling where people are getting sent
off to Rikers Island because they had a
joint in their pocket and so forth and
so on where the real story is kids
learning how to be men from other kids
who've been locked up for five years and
then get out because they all get out go
back to the same neighborhoods and strut
their new bodies and their tattoos and
they're hardened attitudes as a part of
the social counseling that ends up
forming the normative structure of these
communities and I'm talking about tens
upon tens upon tens of thousands of them
in and out in and out of this system if
I may say so how dare a Harvard
professor and a president of the United
States cheapen the serious political
conversation that we have to have about
locking up millions of our fellow
citizens by repairing to a pat all too
familiar a storyline about racism and
profiling in the abstract against black
men in general even on Martha's Vineyard
I'm telling you that that is not the
politics of change that we were promised
during the campaign of 2008